aujourd'hui en 2023 face au risque de
pauvreté et d'exclusion sociale qui
progresse effectivement face au crise
qui fragilise les Européens les classes
moyennes ne sont pas épargnés je suis
frappé de voir dans différentes récentes
enquêtes la peur de nos concitoyens de
tomber dans la pauvreté et leurs
inquiétudes sur le pouvoir d'achat donc
assez grande crise s'ajoutent les
grandes mutations dans le monde du
travail dû à l'automne l'automatisation
et ses conséquences sur l'emploi donc
plus que jamais nous devons défendre une
Europe sociale et inclusive s'appuyant
sur les 20 grands principes du socle
européen des droits sociaux avec des
emplois de qualité des salaires décents
des conventions collectives bien
négociées la lutte contre la précarité
énergétique nous devons aussi rappeler
toutes les opportunités sur lesquelles
nous avons voté dans cette mandature
telle que le plan de relance le Green
Deal le Fond Social climat la
réindustrialisation de l'Union
européenne les plans de reconversion et
de perfection nement professionnel enfin
en cette Année européenne des
compétences il faut plus que jamais
investir sur les compétences pour
permettre à nos concitoyens de s'adapter
aux métiers de demain